This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你主持的《学得深刻》（Learn the Hardway）。这个节目关注黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你可以和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着一套精神铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做，聆听去学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
以“学得深刻”的方式，在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷情网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷情网》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last
这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个
target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. Back for another episode. as we break down the psychology of our 20s. I want to begin this episode with a question. How many friendships do you have with people who don't live in the same state, same city, even the same country as you? Quickly do the math. How many long-distance friendships do you have?
目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝，女朋友们》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴有你们在这里。又迎来了新的一期节目，让我们一起来剖析二十几岁的心理学。我想以一个问题开始这一期节目。你有多少朋友是和你不在同一个州、同一个城市，甚至不在同一个国家的？快在脑海里算一算。你有多少段异地友谊？
So the average number for people in their 20s is between two to five people. Two to five of the people we consider friends are people who we might not. see for months on end, sometimes even years. They are the people that we stay connected to via text messages and TikToks and rushed voice notes on the train, FaceTime calls when we can, and it can be really, really difficult to sustain those relationships. Only about 50% of long distant friendships are successful in the long term, which you know what? It's either very good odds or very terrifying odds depending on how we see it. And despite that, we go into our long distance friendships with so much optimism and hope
所以，二十几岁的人的平均异地朋友数量在两到五个之间。我们认为是朋友的人中，有两到五个可能是我们连续几个月，甚至几年都见不到的人。他们是我们通过短信、TikTok、在火车上匆忙录制的语音便签、能打FacePhone时打FaceTime通话来保持联系的人，要维持这些关系真的非常非常难。只有大约50%的异地友谊能够长期维持，你知道吗？这要么是一个很好的概率，要么是一个非常可怕的概率，这取决于我们如何看待它。尽管如此，我们依然带着极大的乐观和希望步入异地友谊，
because we really care about these people and, you know, what else are we meant to do? If we said goodbye to every single friendship that was inconvenient or every single friendship where distance made it difficult, we would be pretty lonely people because distance, whether it's physical or emotional, is kind of a fact of life. it's a fact of relationships. There are periods of great closeness and then periods where the connection kind of wanes and our 20s are definitely the decade
因为我们真的很在乎这些人，而且，你知道，我们还能做什么呢？如果我们对每一段带来不便的友谊，或者每一段因距离而变得艰难的友谊都说再见，那我们会成为相当孤独的人，因为距离，无论是物理上的还是情感上的，某种程度上是生活中的一个事实。它是人际关系中的一个事实。总会有非常亲密的时期，然后是连接逐渐减弱的时期，而我们的二十岁绝对是
for learning that lesson. In my mind, for the first 18 years of our lives, right? We are typically never more than, I would say 30 minutes away from our friends. We also tend to see each other, probably five days a week at school. And then after we leave high school, we have that first exodus or that first shift of navigating long distance friendships
学习这一课的十年。在我的印象中，在我们生命的前18年里，对吧？通常我们和朋友的距离最多不会超过，我想说是30分钟。我们大概一周有五天在学校见面。然后在我们离开高中之后，当大家为了上大学而各奔东西，或者留在原地时，我们迎来了第一次“大迁徙”，或者说是处理异地友谊的第一次转变，
when we all kind of scatter for college or we stay in the same place. Then we might make new friends at university and often we become even closer with these people. We live with them. We experience many of our first with them until we are hit with that second round of distance post-graduation. Right when, you know, typically we're often at our peak closeness. with people, the relationships start to disperse. I think this is definitely the period where our friendships are tested the most and they become less convenient. It's a bit of a universal experience in
然后我们可能会在大学里结新朋友，通常我们会和这些人变得更加亲密。我们和他们住在一起。和他们一起经历许多“第一次”，直到我们迎来毕业后的第二波距离考验。没错，你知道，通常在（关系）达到最亲密的顶峰时，这些关系开始分散。我认为这绝对是我们的友谊受到最大考验、变得越来越不方便的时期。在我看来，
my mind, a bit of a right of passage. We move from high school to university and then we move for our careers and then we move just for fun. And it seems like everyone we know and love at times is kind of sprawled across the world and we're living these very distinct separate lives. Of course, we still have the friends that have stayed in the same place or who have moved with us. But for those long-distance friendships, things do shift and yet we still really want to be part of each other's reality. We don't want to give up the friendship. So today I want to talk about why we don't have to and how we can make it work. I also really want to explore what exactly happens to a relationship when we add in distance and how to make sure that those long distance friendships
这算是一种普遍经历，一种必经的成年礼。我们从高中到大学，然后为了事业搬迁，接着又为了好玩而搬家。有时候，似乎我们认识和爱着的每个人都散落在世界各地，我们过着非常截然不同、各自独立的生活。当然，我们依然有那些留在原地或跟我们一起搬家的朋友。但对于那些异地友谊，情况确实发生了变化，然而我们依然非常渴望成为彼此现实生活的一部分。我们不想放弃这段友谊。所以今天我想谈谈为什么我们不必放弃，以及我们该如何让它维持下去。我也非常想探讨，当我们加入距离这一要素时，一段关系究竟会发生什么变化，以及如何确保这些异地友谊
continue to be fulfilling, they continue to be deep and vulnerable and incredible. You know, I have some of my own strategies and I've really come up with a bit of an essential formula for maintaining long distance friendships. Plus, you all the listeners, we're kind enough to provide your own tips and tricks that have helped you through the years. So I'm excited to hear from some of you. Let me just say this episode is coming at a great time for me. This year I went through a period where three of my closest friends all moved overseas
继续保持充实、深厚、充满脆弱感和不可思议的美好。你知道的，我有一些自己的策略，而且我确实总结出了一套维护异地友谊的基本公式。此外，你们所有听众也非常慷慨地分享了多年来帮助你们度过难关的独家小贴士和秘诀。所以我很高兴听到你们的一些分享。请容许我先说，这一集播客来得正是时候。今年我经历了一段时期，我最要好的三个朋友都在
in pretty quick succession. So it has definitely been a year of playing a lot of phone tag and just adjusting to this new reality with them. I also have a lot of really important friends with whom, you know, I haven't lived in the same city as for 13, 10, 5 years or so. So I was definitely paying pretty close attention to what you guys had to say, what you've learned from your own experiences, and of course the research. I also want us to leave some space to consider what happens when long distance friendships aren't working out and when they become pretty strained. You know, when exactly is it time to release someone? When is it time to grieve a friendship that didn't survive the long distance phase? We've got to talk about that as well, amongst all the other positive, optimistic things that we'll cover.
相当紧凑的时间里相继搬到了海外。所以今年绝对是充满电话留言乒乓（电话互相错过）、以及努力适应和他们之间这种新现实的一年。我还有很多非常重要的朋友，你知道的，我已经有13年、10年、5年左右没和他们在同一个城市生活过了。所以我一直在非常仔细地倾听你们要说的话，倾听你们从自身经验中学到的东西，当然还有研究。我也希望我们留出一些空间，来思考当异地友谊无法维持、关系变得相当紧张时会发生什么。你知道的，究竟什么时候才是该放手的时候？什么时候是该为一段未能熬过异地阶段的友谊感到悲伤的时候？除了我们要讨论的其他所有积极、乐观的事情之外，我们也必须谈谈这一点。
With all that in mind, there is so much psychology, so much advice, so much evidence to talk about today. So without further ado, let's get into it. Taking a close relationship and adding distance can cause a lot of emotional, social, relational changes. And the biggest one, the biggest contributor to the difference that we notice, I think comes down to a lack of convenience, a lack of proximity, and a decrease in shared memories, all of which are very well-known, crucial elements of friendship. I will say we do know that these ingredients are really important, but they're especially important when a friendship is just getting started and in its infancy. That is why relationships can still survive long distance when they've been around for a while.
考虑到所有这些，今天有太多的心理学、太多的建议、太多的证据要谈。所以废话不多说，让我们切入正题。把一段紧密的亲密关系加上距离，会引发许多情感、社会和关系方面的变化。其中最大的变化、也是导致我们注意到这些差异的最大因素，我认为归结于便利性的缺乏、邻近性的缺乏以及共同回忆的减少，所有这些都是众所周知的、维持友谊至关重要的要素。我要说的是，我们确实知道这些成分非常重要，但当一段友谊刚刚开始、正处于萌芽期时，它们尤其重要。这就是为什么当关系已经维持了一段时间时，它们依然能在异地生存下来。
You know, if we didn't have the convenience, proximity and shared memories at the beginning, then the relationships are more likely to fail. But normally, when we decide to be friends and continue a friendship with someone who is moving away or when we're moving away, it's because we've already got this foundation of trust, of familiarity, of similarity, and of some other essential element, this element of knowledge and being seen by the other person that makes us feel like to lose them would almost be to lose a part of ourselves. So it's really difficult when a friendship is impacted by distance, but it's not a death sentence
你知道，如果在刚开始时我们没有那种便利性、邻近性和共同回忆，那么这些关系更有可能破裂。但通常情况下，当我们决定与一个即将搬走的人做朋友并维系这段友谊，或者当我们自己搬走时，是因为我们已经有了信任、熟悉感、相似性的基础，以及其他一些必不可少的元素——即被对方了解和看见的元素，这让我们觉得失去他们几乎就像失去自己的一部分一样。所以，当友谊受到距离的影响时，确实非常困难，但这绝对不是判了死刑，
by any means, especially to establish friendships. Despite that, it does make it harder to connect. When we are closer, we can just naturally do more things with our friends and we can do more of those filler activities. And it's those filler activities that really help us bond and make shared memories. Shared memories are key for long-term social bonding. There was a 2022 study that found that the more autobiographical and specific memories that we share with others, the closer we tend to feel.
特别是对于已经建立起来的友谊而言。尽管如此，这确实让联系变得更加困难。当我们靠得更近时，我们可以很自然地和朋友一起做更多的事情，我们可以做更多那些填补时间的活动。正是这些填补时间的活动真正帮助我们建立了情感纽带并创造了共同回忆。共同回忆是长期社交结合的关键。2022年的一项研究发现，我们与他人分享的自传体和具体回忆越多，我们往往就会感到彼此越亲密。
And what that essentially means is that the more moments that our friends are around for, and the more moments that we can look back on and see our friend in the background, or by our side, the greater our level of intimacy. It's, you know, really wonderful when we do get to see our long-distance best friends for a weekend or at a friend's wedding or at a big celebration. And of course, we're going to take any of the time that we can get with them. But in my opinion, the thing that I really miss the most is the errands. It's running into each other on the street.
而这基本上意味着，我们的朋友在场见证的时刻越多，我们能够回首过去并看到朋友在背景中或在我们身旁出现的时刻越多，我们的亲密度水平就越高。你知道的，每当我们在周末、朋友的婚礼上或盛大的庆祝活动中见到我们异地的好友时，那种感觉真的很美妙。当然，我们会抓住任何能和他们在一起的时间。但在我看来，我真正最怀念的其实是那些琐事。是在街上偶遇。
It's like grabbing a quick coffee. The, you know, want to get a drink text. knowing that you can both be ready in 10 minutes. It's that instant gratification of having that person around and knowing that they could be at your house, you know, in a second. I reminisce on this all the time with my friend Aaron, who I talk about so often on the show, when we lived in Canberra together, and it's been four years now since that was the case, but when we did live only 100 metres away from each other, my favorite thing to do with
就像顺便喝杯快咖啡。你知道的，发一句“想去喝一杯”的短信。知道你们俩都可以在10分钟内准备好。那种身边有个人、并且知道他们转眼就能到你家的即时满足感。我总是和我的朋友艾伦（Aaron）回忆起这些，我在节目中经常提起她。我们以前一起住在堪培拉，距离现在已经四年了，但当时我们确实只相距100米，我和她最喜欢做的事情
her would be grocery shopping. And that is something that is so boring and plain, but we would walk up and down the aisles for hours and hours just chatting. And then we would come home and I'd sit on her couch while she cleaned. There was no fanfare. It was just so simple. It was so every day. And at the time, I didn't realize how nostalgic I would one day be for that opportunity to just have that everyday closeness with someone and especially with such a, good friend, there's also something to be said for the value of in-person contact, right?
就是去买杂货。这听起来是一件多么无聊和普通的事，但我们会手拉手在过道里走上好几个小时，只是不停地聊天。然后我们回到家，当她打扫卫生时，我坐在她的沙发上。没有什么大张旗鼓。就是这么简单。就是这么日常。当时，我并没有意识到，有一天我会如此怀念那种能和某人拥有日常亲密感的机遇，尤其是和这样一个好朋友在一起。关于面对面接触的价值，也同样值得探讨，
Like, nothing beats it. Even as we look for online substitutions and solutions, getting to just see your friend and give them a big hug and just talk to them and hear their laughter, like, as you see it, and responding to the same things, experiencing the same things, that's pretty special. And it goes without saying that a relationship that is defined by solely online interactions, it can feel slightly colder, it can feel a little bit more plain, but that just makes the time that you do spend together physically a lot more special. And I like to think about, you know, how many people were able to make friendships and who made relationships that survived for decades doing long distance before technology.
比如，没有什么能比得上它。即便我们在寻找网上的替代品和解决方案，能够亲眼见到你的朋友，给他们一个大大的拥抱，和他们交谈并听见他们的笑声——就像你亲眼所见那样，对同样的事情作出反应，经历同样的事情，那是非常特别的。不言而喻，一段完全由网络互动定义的 pentru（法语/笔误：应为关系），可能会感觉稍微冷淡一些，可能会感觉更平淡一点，但这只会让你们实际花时间在一起的时刻变得更加特别。我喜欢去想，在科技出现之前，有多少人能够建立友谊并维持长达几十年的异地关系。
You know, there were people who would go away for years at a time and they'd come back and their family would still be there, their friends would still be there, we'd pick up like there was old times, like it was old times. And during those periods away, you know, they would, there would be limited communication. There would be a lot of slow communication. That is something that we're actually going to talk about a little bit later on, why traditional forms of communication, like letters and photos and postcards, are very, very special for a long distance friendship, not to offer any spoilers. But a lack of convenience. a lack of proximity and physical contact, that can make long-distance friendships
你知道的，有些人会离开好几年，然后他们回来时，他们的家人依然在那里，他们的朋友依然在那里，我们会像过去一样重新开始，就像过去的好时光一样。而在那些离开的日子里，你知道，交流会是有限的。那会是很多缓慢的交流。这其实是我们稍后要讨论的一点，为什么传统的交流方式，比如信件、照片和明信片，对于异地友谊来说是非常非常特别的，这里就不剧透了。但是，缺乏便利性、
especially hard in the weeks, in the months and the early days, especially right after a move. It can feel kind of awkward almost as you like adjust to this new chapter of your relationship. And I really want to make that known. It is going to be difficult. It's okay to feel like this is a little bit weird. It's quite hard to effortlessly slide into an online relationship, especially one that is across time zones, across cities, across countries. And this may sound controversial to some, and I totally accept if you don't agree with this.
缺乏邻近感和身体接触，这会让异地友谊在几周、几个月和早期，特别是搬家后的那段日子里，变得格外艰难。当你适应关系的这个新篇章时，甚至可能会感到有点尴尬。我真的很想让大家知道这一点。这将会是困难的。感觉这有点怪异是正常的。要毫不费力地过渡到一种网络关系中是相当困难的，特别是那种跨越时区、跨越城市、跨越国家的关系。这在有些人听来可能会觉得很有争议，如果你不同意这一点，我完全接受。
But I was talking to my friend about this the other day, and I came across this point that your friendships shouldn't automatically improve when you go long distance. And the same goes for a romantic relationship as well. Your friendship actually should not be at its best when you are not seeing each other often. I think that immediate dip and that insecurity that you may feel when the distance first begins, it's very uncomfortable. But I think it's also a sign of how much this friendship means to you and how much you don't want to lose them. If it was effortless, if it was like, wow, I barely even notice that you're gone.
但我前几天和我的朋友聊起这个时，我偶然想到了这样一个观点：当你开始异地时，你们的友谊不应该自动变好。浪漫关系也是如此。当你们不常常见面时，你们的友谊其实不应该处于最佳状态。我认为，当距离刚开始时，那种即时的低落和可能感到的不安全感是非常不舒服的。但我认为这也是一个信号，表明这段友谊对你有多重要，以及你有多么不想失去对方。如果一切毫不费力，如果感觉就像是：哇，我几乎都没注意到你离开了。
You kind of have to consider, like, how close were we really? So it's actually totally normal to worry about things changing, to worry about the friends, friendship not being the same, to worry about losing them, I think that those fears are actually a really beautiful indication of a very deep love. Let's also talk about something else that is bound to come up in not even the early days, but just in the history of, and in the journey of a long distance friendship. And that is like the awkwardness around forgetting to talk for a little while and forgetting to call for a few months and playing phone tag and feeling like the dynamic has changed, you talk to each other less, because life is just busy and it's hard to pick up the phone.
你可能就得思考一下：我们以前到底有多亲密？所以，担心事情会发生变化、担心友谊不再如初、担心失去对方，其实是完全正常的。我认为这些恐惧实际上是对一种非常深沉的爱的绝佳表现。我们再来谈谈另一件注定会在异地友谊的早期、甚至在它的历史和旅程中都会出现的事情。那就是围绕着有一段时间忘记了交谈、几个月忘记了打电话、互相玩电话传话（错过电话）、以及感觉动态已经改变了的尴尬感，你们聊天变少了，因为生活本就忙碌，而且很难拿起电话。
I think the guilt that follows that, the guilt that you aren't as close anymore, that becomes a real obstacle in continuing to be friends with someone. You cannot have guilt in a relationship and hope that it survives. And often I'll see people who, you know, are like, well, it's just been too long. I just shouldn't message them. It's just going to be really, really awkward. That is not what we are looking for. We need to be able to swallow our pride and just say, you know, I've got a lot on my plate. Let's just get right back to normal. Let's just return to how we were.
我认为随之而来的负罪感——那种你不再那么亲密的负罪感，会成为继续与某人保持友谊的真正障碍。在一段关系中，你不能带着负罪感，还指望它能存活。我经常看到有人说：“好吧，已经隔太久了。我真不该给他们发信息。这会变得非常非常尴尬。”这可不是我们想要的。我们需要能够咽下自尊，直接说：“你知道的，我手头有很多事。让我们直接回到正轨吧。让我们回到以前的样子。”
Because we do begin our long-distance friendships with a lot of optimism. And we want to talk to them every day. We want to still be involved. But it is difficult, especially perhaps when you're the one who has moved away and you're kind of swept up into your new life. You are facing the pressure to find you friends. to find your footing. I think that our attachment to our previous life for a while can naturally just be a little bit neglected. But the more you avoid calling, talking, finding the time for a face time, the harder it's going to become, and I'm speaking from experience, you don't have to
因为我们在开始异地友谊时确实抱有很大的乐观。我们想每天和他们聊天。我们还想继续参与其中。但这很难，尤其是当你可能是那个搬走、并且被卷入新生活的人时。你面临着寻找新朋友、找到立足点的压力。我认为，我们在一段时间内对之前生活的依恋，自然而然地会被稍微忽视。但是，你越是逃避打电话、交谈、腾出时间进行FaceTime，事情就会变得越困难。我这是在凭经验说话，你不需要
devote an hour. But when you're thinking about your friend, when you see something that reminds you of them, those are small touch points throughout your day that they are important to you, and you should just communicate that to them. Call them for 10 minutes when you're on the train. Send them the picture of the thing that reminds them of you, you know, anything it is, send them the song that you're listening to. When they come into your mind, just let them know and find the convenience that you used to have because of proximity in this new form. So I'm already skipping ahead into my tips. I'm already giving away the secrets. We're not even there yet. We're not even in that section. What I really want to give you before we get into the specific things is the formula that
投入一个小时。但当你想到你的朋友，当你看到让你想起他们的东西时，这些都是你一天中微小的接触点，它们对你很重要，你应该把这些传达给他们。在火车上时给他们打10分钟电话。把让你想起他们的东西的照片发给他们，无论是什么，把你在听的歌发给他们。当他们浮现在你脑海时，让他们知道，并用这种新形式来找回你们曾经因为邻近而拥有的便利。所以，我已经提前剧透了我的小贴士。我已经把秘密泄露了。我们甚至还没到那一步。我们甚至还没到那个板块。在我讲具体的事情之前，我真正想给你们的是
I have and that I deeply believe in for managing long distance relationships. And I actually talk very extensively about this formula in my book that comes out in April. But since that's a while away, I'm just going to give you the Cliff Note version now because it's too valuable not to share. Maintaining a long term, long distance friendship is a combination of effort, patience, opportunity and managing expectations. So that's the formula. Effort, patience, opportunity and managing expectations. If I was smarter about this, I would have come up with like a cool little anagram word for it. I haven't done that, but you know, someone can do that. The only word I can think of is mope, which isn't going to work for this. But let's go through each of these different
我拥有的、并且深信不疑的用来管理异地关系的公式。其实我在四月份出版的书里非常广泛地谈到了这个公式。但既然离那还有段时间，我现在就给出“精简版”，因为这个内容太有价值了，不分享不行。维持长期、异地的友谊是努力、耐心、契机和管理期望的结合。这就是那个公式。努力、耐心、契机和管理期望。如果我更聪明一点的话，我本可以为它想出一个很酷的缩写词。我还没做到这一点，但你知道的，别人可以去试试。我能想到的唯一一个词是mope（沮丧），这在这个语境下行不通。但让我们来逐一看看这个等式的各个不同
elements of this equation. So effort. Relationships, they do not just happen without some, form of investment, even if there is distance involved. So you have to be intentional and you have to really decide, you know, if you're the one moving, if someone has moved, do I want this person in my life? Because if I do, it is going to be an investment and it is going to take time. You have to make plans. You have to make each other part of your routine. You have to do the weekly, monthly phone calls, the monthly trips, the yearly trips, the long voice notes. You know, you have to show up for your friends by keeping your finger on the pulse of their lives. I've found the best way to get a sense of whether I really know what's happening with one of my long distance friends is to know and be
元素。首先，努力。人际关系不会凭空发生，不付出某种形式的投资是不行的，即便其中涉及距离。所以你必须是有意图的，你必须真正决定——如果你是搬走的那个人，或者如果有人搬走了——我想要这个人出现在我的生活里吗？因为如果我想要，这将是一项投资，这需要时间。你必须做出计划。你必须让彼此成为你日常生活的一部分。你必须进行每周、每月的电话沟通，每月的旅行，每年的旅行，长长的语音便签。你知道的，你必须通过掌握他们生活的脉搏来为你的朋友出现。我发现，要了解自己是否真的清楚某个异地朋友的生活发生了什么，最好的方法是了解并
aware of the following things. I should know what they're looking forward to. I should know what they're struggling with and I should know what they're focused on or interested in at the moment. So like what's something that they're loving like a TV show. Those three things are really good indicators as to the health of my long-distance friendship. The second important part of this formula is patience. It probably should be number one. People aren't always going to be who we want them to be. Long-distance friendships can be frustrating,
意识到以下事情。我应该知道他们在期待什么。我应该知道他们在挣扎什么，我应该知道他们目前关注的是什么或对什么感兴趣。比如他们现在超爱的一部电视剧是什么。这三件事是我异地友谊健康状况的极好指标。这个公式的第二个重要部分是耐心。它大概应该排在第一位。人们并不总是会成为我们希望他们成为的样子。异地友谊可能会令人沮丧，
especially when we are now separate and dealing with our own complex, internal and external lives as well. But all good long-lasting love involves a very healthy dose of patience. This is especially true if you have a friend who is not in the same place, time zone, country as you. The golden rule is to show your friends the grace that you would appreciate in their circumstances. And I have definitely been on the receiving end of this patience more time than I can count. You know, it's probably saved quite a few friendships of mine. Was my friends really being like, yeah, I get that this is a transitional,
特别是当我们现在分隔两地，并且各自还要应对复杂、内部和外部的生活时。但所有美好的、长久的爱都包含着非常健康的耐心。如果你有一个不在同一个地方、时区、国家的朋友，这一点尤其如此。黄金法则就是，要给予你的朋友你在他们的处境下会感激的那种宽容。我已经数不清自己有多少次得到过这种耐心的眷顾了。你知道的，这大概拯救了我好几个友谊。我的朋友们真的很体谅：“是的，我明白这是你生活中的一个过渡期、
transformative period for you. I'll be patient and I'll wait until this is a better time. I'll wait until you come back. As in like until I'm ready to come back into their lives, not like come back to where they are geographically wise. So you really do have to be patient. The next important ingredient is opportunity. Effort is one thing and it's a big thing. But sometimes there are just moments in a friendship that happen by coincidence and just take things to the next level. You can't always plan or predict what these moments might be, but you have to be open to the opportunity of getting a surprise chance to see them, or the opportunity to meet each other in the middle, the opportunity to have them stay for a weekend, even if it's last minute, to go to the
变革期。我会保持耐心，等到时机更好时再说。我会等到你回来。”这里的“回来”是指等我准备好重新回到他们的生活中，而不是指在地理位置上回到他们身边。所以你真的必须要有耐心。下一个重要的成分是契机。努力是一回事，而且是一件大事。但有时友谊中就是会出现一些纯属巧合、能把关系提升到新水平的时刻。你无法总是计划或预测这些时刻会是什么，但你必须对获得一个惊喜相见的机会持开放态度，或者获得在中间某个地方碰面的机会，或者让他们留宿一个周末的机会，哪怕是最后一分钟决定的，去看
concert or, you know, to pick up the phone and call them just when you feel like it. There are moments when we can reconnect in very special circumstances. And it's really hard sometimes because you're busy, you're tired, you're used to a different life without the minute. There is always going to be a million excuses as to why they can't sleep on your floor and why you can't make that weekend work. I'm telling you now, in hindsight, you're going to wish that you had taken the opportunity and just run with it.
演唱会，或者，你知道的，仅仅在你想这么做的时候拿起电话打给他们。在非常特殊的情况下，总会有一些我们可以重新建立联系的时刻。有时这真的很艰难，因为你很忙，你很累，你习惯了没有这一分钟的另一种生活。关于他们为什么不能睡在你地板上、为什么你无法抽出那个周末的借口，永远都会有一百万个。我现在就告诉你，事后诸葛亮来看，你会希望自己当初抓住了那个契机并顺其自然。
You're going to wish that you'd made the time. So finding and taking advantage of opportunities to say, see each other or to reconnect, just as valuable as effort. And finally, this one's quite similar to patience, but maintaining long-distance friendships really requires adjusting your expectations. And that can mean for communication, but also just adjusting the role that they might play in your life, how much you can rely on them, how much you can essentially rely on each other. This also comes down to boundaries and being really our time.
你会希望自己当时腾出了时间。所以，寻找并利用各种机会去见一见对方或重新建立联系，和努力一样具有价值。最后，这一点和耐心很相似，但维持异地友谊确实需要调整你的期望。这不仅意味着对沟通的期望，也意味着调整他们在你生活中的角色、你可以多大程度上依赖他们、以及你们可以基本上多大程度上依赖彼此。这也归结于边界感，并且明确我们的时间。
about what you need from this friendship. If you can't call once a week, if that's too much of a mental burden for you or you're just so busy, tell them that. If you prefer voice notes to FaceTime's, tell them that. If you prefer Instagram to Snapchat, like whatever your communication medium is, make sure that you're clear on expectations around how often you're going to communicate, how deep that communication is going to be, what you're you. You're going to be. you can expect from each other in certain moments. I think people, I don't think, I know actually, I'm going to change this statement. I know, and you know as well, people change over time. And loving them means letting them do so. They might not be the first person that you call
关于你从这段友谊中需要什么。如果你不能一周打一次电话，如果这给你带来了太多的心理负担或者你实在太忙，那就告诉他们。如果你比起FaceTime更喜欢语音便签，那就告诉他们。如果你比起Snapchat更喜欢Instagram，无论你的沟通媒介是什么，都要确保你们对沟通频率、沟通深度、以及在某些时刻你们可以
with good news anymore, but just because the relationship has changed doesn't mean that it should be discarded. Just because things have shifted doesn't mean that you should listen to your first instinct to panic, to abandon the relationship before you get hurt, to move on with your lives. I think instead it's important to have a conversation that could really save an important friendship to you. So that was my very, very general formula. But I also want to move into some of the specific creative fun ways
对彼此抱有什么期望，达成共识。我认为人们——我不认为，其实我知道，我要改变这个说法。我知道，而且你也知道，人们是会随时间改变的。爱他们就意味着让他们去改变。他们可能不再是你在有好消息时第一个打电话的人了，但仅仅因为关系变了，并不意味着它就应该被抛弃。仅仅因为情况发生了变化，并不意味着你应该听从内心的第一直觉去恐慌、在受到伤害之前放弃这段关系、然后继续你们各自的生活。相反，我认为重要的是进行一次对话，这可能会真正挽救一段对你很重要的友谊。这就是我非常非常通用的公式。但我也想进入一些具体的、有创意的、有趣的方式，
that you can keep the spark alive in your long-distance friendships. Some of these are from you guys, from our wonderful listeners. And some of them, let me just say, are genius. They're just wonderful. So we are going to take a quick break. But when we return, I want to dive into these practical tips. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
你可以用这些方式在异地友谊中保持火花。其中一些来自你们，来自我们可爱的听众。其中一些，我得说，简直是天才般的创意。它们太美妙了。所以我们将进行一个简短的休息。但当我们回来时，我们将深入探讨这些实用的建议。《2%》。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness. fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性的科学。健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will calm out. on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你最终会平静下来。在另一边，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听TWO percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMAs上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什和小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.），我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作客，大谈80年代的快克（毒品）。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我可以聊聊当年的快克，只是为了让你们都知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线了。我们现在桌上还有艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《学得深刻》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine），瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而我们还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于赢输的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns），达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《学得深刻》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的Our Heart Radio应用。搜索《学得深刻》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这动用了大批网络侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯比安（Greg Alesbian），迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I asked you all over on Instagram, what is your best advice or the best thing that you have told about maintaining a long-distance friendship, you pulled through like I have never seen before.
这是《深陷情网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷情网》播客。当我向Instagram上的所有人发问：关于维持异地友谊，你得到的最好建议或最好的事情是什么时，你们给予的支持是我从未见过的。
I, like the amount of responses I got, I just feel like that is further evidence to me of how universal this experience is, especially in this decade and the real challenge that comes with navigating relationship with someone despite obstacles. So I couldn't even count. I think I received over 500 responses. And first things first, because I can't possibly list them all. the major themes or the general pieces of advice that came from you guys were to schedule regular calls to find easy ways to keep in touch so that convenient factor plan when you see each other next
我，收到的回复数量之多，让我觉得这进一步证明了这种经历是多么具有普遍性，尤其是在这个十年里，以及伴随着在面对阻碍时如何与某人维持关系的真正挑战。所以我根本数不过来。我想我收到了超过500条回复。首先，因为我不可能把它们全列出来，你们给出的主要主题或一般性建议是：安排定期通话，寻找简单的方式保持联系以保持便利因素，计划下一次见面的时间，
but also be forgiving because life gets busy and you know you're living different lives now patience keeps coming up both from me both from you guys it's probably the most important thing to remember in these relationships. But here were the more specific ideas. So this one I heard from three people, and I was actually reading it and being like, I wonder if these people are friends, and it's worked for all of them so they're all sharing the idea
但也要学会包容，因为生活很忙碌，而且你知道你们现在过着不同的生活。耐心这个词不断出现，无论是我还是你们，这大概是这些关系中最需要记住的重要事情。但这里有一些更具体的主意。这个我从三个人那里听说过，我当时读到时还在想：“不知道这几个人是不是朋友，这招对他们都管用，所以他们都在分享这个想法。”
because there was only three people who mentioned it, and I was like, this is so similar. And the idea is called Waffle Wednesdays. Really cute name to begin. But basically the premises they told me was that on Wednesday, every person in their group chat or either party of a friendship, you have to send a big voice note or a big waffle to each other with everything from the huge life updates to the minor things,
因为只有三个人提到它，而我觉得这太相似了。这个点子叫做“华夫饼星期三”（Waffle Wednesdays）。首先名字就很可爱。但基本上他们告诉我的前提是，在星期三，群聊里的每个人或友谊双方，都必须给彼此发一条长长的语音便签或者一个大大的“华夫饼”（指长篇大论），里面包含一切内容，从巨大的生活更新到琐碎的小事，
the TV show you're watching, the bug that you killed in your bathroom, your new favorite workout. Just give them a big, deep dive into your life. I really loved that they spoke about not just focusing on the big things, but making sure that you also share the small, mundane details as well. I do this with my friends by sending them random things I want to buy or like, you know, I'll send them pictures of a haircut or different haircuts that I want and I'll be like,
比如你正在看的电视剧、你在浴室里拍死的虫子、你新喜欢的健身项目。只要让他们对你的生活进行一次深入的了解。我真的很喜欢他们谈到不仅要关注大事，还要确保分享那些小的、世俗的细节。我通常会通过发一些我想买的随机东西来和朋友们这样做，或者，你知道的，我会发一些发型照片或者我想要的不同发型给他们，然后我会说：
oh, you should choose. You keep them engaged. This was also a cute idea and it comes back to that concept of slow communication or snail mail that we talked about before. It's sending each other letters sending each other handwritten letters with maybe a nice envelope a nice stamp just so that people feel more special about your communication it might be more rare but maybe that's like the really special part you're really excited to read their 12 15 20 page note or maybe just the one page letter care packages are another thing I do this with my friends oh my god I'm going to bring up Erin again, but she is like one of my most significant long distance friendships. And we've been doing it for a while. And for Christmas this year, I sent her a bunch of chocolate.
“哦，你应该选这个。”这样可以让他们保持参与。这也是一个可爱的点子，它回到了我们之前讨论过的缓慢沟通或慢邮的概念。给彼此写信，寄手写信，可能配上一个好看的信封、一张漂亮的邮票，只是为了让人觉得你们的交流更加特别。这可能更罕见，但也许那就是真正特别的部分，你会非常兴奋地阅读他们12页、15页、20页的信，或者仅仅是一页纸的信。大礼包是另一回事，我经常和朋友们这样做。哦天哪，我又要提起艾伦了，但她确实是我最重要的异地好友之一。我们这样做好一阵子了。今年圣诞节，我给她寄了一堆巧克力。
She lives in Tasmania that she can't get, you know, that's only available in the mainland of Australia. So care packages, try not to forget Christmas birthdays, or just send them things when you feel like it. You know, it's so exciting to get something in the mail from someone you love with heaps of little treats and special things. It is all. Also a really good reminder, speaking of writing letters, speaking of gifts, to continue communicating in each other's love language even when you are miles apart. Obviously, you know, it's really hard to continue communicating through quality time or through physical touch.
她住在塔斯马尼亚，有些东西你买不到，你知道的，那些只在澳大利亚本土供应。所以关怀包裹，尽量不要忘记圣诞节、生日，或者只是在你想起的时候给他们寄点东西。你知道的，收到你爱的人寄来的、装满各种小零食和特别物件的邮件，是多么令人兴奋的一件事啊。这其实也是一个很好的提醒，说到写信，说到礼物，即使你们相隔数英里，也要继续用彼此的爱的语言进行交流。显然，你知道的，要通过共度高质量时光或通过身体接触来维持交流真的很难。
That's the big one. But try and find ways that you continue to show them love in the format that they might desire. So for quality time, as an example, instead of just FaceTiming and talking for 20 minutes, you guys could do activities together or you could do watch parties or you could do the word or the connections or the Sunday quiz together as a way to like build this quality time that you feel like you're spending with each other. So I find that really, really important. You know, if you're someone who is in a words of affirmation person, you might not want to jump on a call and be like, oh, I miss you, I miss you, I miss you every week. But you might really want to
这是最重要的一点。但请试着寻找各种方法，以他们可能渴望的形式继续向他们表达爱。例如，对于高质量时光，与其只是进行FaceTiming并聊上20分钟，你们可以一起做活动，或者可以一起看视频，或者可以一起做文字游戏、连线游戏或周日问答，以此来建立这种你觉得是在陪伴彼此的高质量时光。所以我觉得这真的、真的非常重要。你知道的，如果你是一个倾向于肯定言语的人，你可能不想每周都打个电话说，哦，我想你，我想你，我想你。但你可能真的很想
receive a really nice gift or just to receive a message from someone being like, yeah, I'm just thinking about you. This one person, and this one was really, really interesting, only one person sent this in, and I loved her idea. And what she does is that she shares a journal with her friend. Love this. So they have this journal. They send it back and forth. I was also like, who's going to keep this journal when it's done, when it's finished? Maybe it's something that like deserves to be a museum of committed friendships because that is just such a beautiful, beautiful idea. And you could like put stickers on it and like decorate it. So every time it comes back to that person, it's different.
收到一份非常好的礼物，或者只是收到某人发来的消息说，是的，我只是在想你。有这样一个人，这个特别有意思，只有一个人发了这个过来，我特别喜欢她的主意。她做的是和她的朋友共用一本日志。太棒了。所以她们有这样一本日志。她们把它寄来寄去。我当时还想，这本日志写完后，最终会由谁来保存呢？也许这应该成为一个致力于坚定友谊的博物馆的藏品，因为这真的是一个非常非常美好的主意。你还可以在上面贴贴纸并进行装饰。所以每次它回到那个人手上时，都是崭新的。
Very sisterhood of the traveling pants vibes. Watch that movie the other day. It was gorgeous. It was beautiful. If you actually are in a long distance friendship, watch that together. It's such a great movie. This was another tip. Have a close friends story where you can just share whatever you want.
很有《牛仔裤的夏天》那种氛围。前几天刚看了那部电影。太精彩了。太美了。如果你真的处于一段异地友谊中，一起看看那部电影吧。真的是一部很棒的电影。这是另一个小建议。建立一个密友快拍，在那里你可以随心所欲地分享任何你想分享的东西。
Like there's no pressure of judgment from people. not close with or who isn't, you know, a long distance friend. My friend E.J., she does this. She just recently moved to London. And I love her close friend's story because, firstly, she's just very, very funny. So it's like always quite hilarious. And yeah, I'm just thinking about some of the stuff she posted today. And I'm like, yes, she's a funny girl.
就像没有来自那些跟你不熟、或者不是异地好友的人的评判压力一样。我的朋友E.J.就是这么做的。她最近刚搬到伦敦。我很喜欢她的密友快拍，因为首先，她非常非常搞笑。所以总是相当欢乐。是的，我刚好想起她今天发的 některé 内容，我就觉得，没错，她是个有趣的女孩。
But it's also just really special to like have this look into her brain and to like see the pop culture things or the songs that she's listening to, even though she's, She's on the literal other side of the world. Sending photo dumps to each other with captions instead of doing long paragraphs. Also a really great way to do this as well. This final piece, this final thing is not so much as a tip as it is a piece of advice. And it really hit home for me. Remember that they don't hate you just because they are not messaging you as much.
但能这样一窥她的内心世界，看到流行文化的事物或者她正在听的歌，也真的非常特别，哪怕她身处地球的另一端。彼此发送带有说明文字的照片集，而不是写长篇大论。这也是一个非常棒的方法。这最后一点，这个最后的事情与其说是一个小技巧，不如说是一个忠告。它真的深深触动了我。记住，不要仅仅因为他们不常给你发信息就觉得他们讨厌你。
I think that that is a spectacular reminder. when we are already facing a physical distance between us, sometimes there can also be an emotional distance. We're not quite sure how the other person feels. We're not able to confirm or deny based on the fact that we are seeing them more or seeing them less or having the opportunity to kind of square things away. So what that means is that we can take ambiguous or neutral situations such as not hearing from someone for a while and apply our own anxious meaning, apply an irrational, delusional meaning that they hate us, they're done with us, they don't want to speak to us anymore. Very rarely is that the case. And I want you to think about it from your own perspective.
我觉得这是一个绝妙的提醒。当我们本就要面对彼此之间的身体距离时，有时也会产生情感上的距离。我们不太确定对方的感受。我们无法根据我们见面的多少或是否有机会把事情说清楚来证实或否认这种感觉。所以这意味着，我们可能会把模棱两可或中立的情况（例如一段时间没有听到某人的消息）加上我们自己焦虑的含义，加上一种不理智的、妄想的含义，觉得他们讨厌我们、他们受够我们了、他们不想再和我们说话了。这种情况真的很少见。我希望你从你自己的角度来想想。
You've definitely had times of accidentally doing that to people as well. Life just gets very, very chaotic. So the simplest answer is often the correct one. You don't need to fill in the blanks with fear and with anxiety and with worry, sometimes it is just the fact that people have a lot on their plate and they still absolutely 100% love you. This brings me to something that's very, very important in this discussion. And that is the inevitable friendship fallouts or the friendship fizzles, as I call them, that come from a long distance friendship. There will be some. there will be some friendships that do not last. You know, there's this very famous study by someone called Robin Dunbar,
你肯定也有过不小心对别人做这种事的时候。生活有时变得非常非常混乱。所以最简单的答案往往就是正确的答案。你不需要用恐惧、焦虑和担忧去填补空白，有时事实只是大家都有很多事要忙，而且他们依然百分之百地爱着你。这就引出了本次讨论中非常非常重要的一点。那就是异地友谊带来的不可避免的友谊破裂或友谊消亡，正如我所称的那样。总会有一些这样的情况。总会有一些友谊无法持久。你知道的，罗宾·邓巴（Robin Dunbar）这个人做过一个非常著名的研究，
and he looked into how many relationships we can have at any given time. And essentially what he says is that we are restrained or constrained by the networks in our brain that control how many important relationships could even be held in our minds. So five is how many close friends we can have. 15, how many good friends? So sometimes someone you don't see that often does get bumped. Just because the nature of your relationship has changed and just because they have become, you know, more of an acquaintance, someone you don't speak to every day, every week, maybe even every month, doesn't mean it's over. And I really want that to come across loud and clear.
他研究了我们在任何特定时间可以维系多少段关系。本质上，他所说的是，我们受到大脑中网络的限制或约束，这些网络控制着我们脑海中甚至可以容纳多少段重要的关系。所以，我们能拥有的挚友数量是五个。十五个是好朋友的数量。所以有时，一个你并不常见面的人确实会被降级。仅仅因为你们关系性质的改变，仅仅因为他们变得，你知道的，更像是熟人，一个你不是每天、每周甚至每月都交谈的人，并不意味着一切都结束了。我真的希望这一点能被大家清晰明确地理解。
The changing of a relationship is not the same as the ending of one. sometimes distance just changes where someone sits in our relationship galaxy. So our relationship galaxy is an idea I came up with. And it's a way of organizing basically where people sit in relation to us. And it kind of lets us understand what to expect from people and what they can expect from us in return. So you have three main circles in your galaxy. The inner circle is your closest, longest, strongest, strongest relationship. Not necessarily longest, but the ones that are very, very important to you.
一段关系的改变并不等同于一段关系的结束。有时距离只是改变了某人在我们关系星系中的位置。所以我们的关系星系是我提出的一个概念。这是一种基本上用来组织人们与我们相对位置的方法。它让我们大致了解对他人有什么期望，以及他们又能反过来对我们有什么期望。所以你的星系中有三个主要的圈子。内圈是你最亲密、最持久、最牢固的关系。不一定是时间最长的，但却是对你非常非常重要的关系。
This may include your siblings, your long-term partner, your childhood best friend who's going to be like the honorary aunt to your children. The inner circle is sacred and it is reserved for those that you could ask anything from and they would give it to you. The second circle is for those of those people who you have an ongoing and very close relationship with. It just hasn't reached the intimacy of the inner circle yet. These are the friends that you see regularly. You rely on them for emotional support. You have shared experiences. They're your companions. You might not necessarily turn to them first in a crisis, but they are really, really important to you. You love them. They enrich your daily life. Then the third circle consists of our more distant relationships. This is acquaintances, colleagues, friends that you have grown apart from.
这可能包括你的兄弟姐妹、你的长期伴侣、你童年时期的最好朋友，她会成为你孩子名义上的阿姨。内圈是神圣的，它是为你可以向其求助任何事、而他们也会给予你帮助的人所保留的。第二圈是留给那些与你有着持续且非常亲密关系的人的。只是它还没有达到内圈的那种亲密度。这些是你经常见面的朋友。你依靠他们获得情感支持。你们有着共同的经历。他们是你的同伴。在危机时刻，你未必会第一个向他们求助，但他们真的非常非常重要。你爱他们。他们丰富了你的日常生活。然后第三圈由我们更疏远的关系组成。这就是熟人、同事、渐行渐远的朋友。
These people are still an important part of your life just in a more peripheral way. So they contribute to your social network. They don't necessarily play a central role. And then we have, you know, we could add a fourth circle here. Sometimes I do. And that's the people who you're like, I don't want anything to do with you. You're a stranger to me. Either you're a stranger who I don't know yet or you're someone who I did know who is now
这些人仍然是你生活中的重要部分，只是处于更边缘的位置。所以他们构成了你的社交网络。他们不一定扮演核心角色。然后我们有，你知道的，我们可以在这里加第四个圈子。有时我会这么做。那就是那些你觉得“我不想跟你有任何瓜葛，你对我是个陌生人”的人。要么你是一个我还不认识的陌生人，要么你是一个我曾经认识、而现在由于某些糟糕的原因变成了
a stranger for bad reasons. But really we have the three main circles. Over our lives, I do believe that most people will shift between these circles. Very few can be in the inner circle, so it's quite an exclusive club. But just because they are in your inner circle now, does it mean that they can't one day be in your second or third circle and then return to your inner circle? Essentially, it's not a problem for people to move between the galaxies. It's just that it can be painful.
陌生人的人。但实际上我们有三个主要的圈子。在我们的生活中，我确实相信大多数人会在这些圈子之间转换。很少有人能进入内圈，所以这是一个相当排他的俱乐部。但仅仅因为他们现在在你的内圈，并不意味着有一天他们不能进入你的第二或第三圈，然后又重回你的内圈。本质上，人们在星系之间移动并不是什么问题。只是这个过程可能会很痛苦。
The shift from one galaxy to another can feel quite universe altering because it kind of is. It doesn't mean that they have disappeared. Nothing is stopping them from making their way back into the inner circle. What I really want you to remember, though, is that where someone sits in your galaxy should really reflect how you feel about them and how you treat them. Now, that doesn't mean that the third circle of people that you treat like shit or that you forget about. it's just that your expectations for them are a little bit lower. So, you know, as maybe a best friend who's now become a long distance best friend, as that, as time goes on, you know, they might not be the first person you could call.
从一个星系转移到另一个星系会让人感觉天翻地覆，因为某种程度上确实如此。这并不意味着他们已经消失了。没有什么能阻止他们重新回到内圈。不过，我真正想让你记住的是，某人在你星系中的位置确实应该反映出你对他们的感觉以及你如何对待他们。现在，这并不意味着第三圈的人就是你像对待狗屎一样对待或被你遗忘的人。只是你对他们的期望稍微低了一些。所以，你知道的，作为一个曾经的最好朋友、现在变成了异地最好朋友的人，随着时间的推移，你知道的，他们可能不再是你第一个可以打电话的人。
You might not be able to jump on a plane the same way you could jump in your car and go and help them out. So your expectations for them and your closeness has kind of shifted. And I want us to realize that that is not necessarily a bad thing. In fact, I think that it is a way of adjusting what we expect from someone, how we feel about them without getting hurt. And it's actually a huge sign of respect to look at the relationship and say, hey, this isn't the same that it once was. That doesn't mean that I need to throw the baby out with the bathwater. It doesn't mean that it's over. It's just changed.
你可能无法像开着车去帮他们那样坐飞机去找他们。所以你对他们的期望和亲密度已经发生了转变。我希望我们能意识到这不一定是件坏事。事实上，我认为这是一种调整我们对某人的期望、以及我们对他们的感觉而又不让自己受伤的方式，审视这段关系并说“嘿，这已经不是从前那个样子了”，这实际上是一个巨大的尊重标志。这并不意味着我需要把婴儿和洗澡水一起倒掉。这并不意味着一切都结束了。它只是变了。
Sometimes, though, a friendship, sadly, unfortunately, can feel... beyond saving. Or what's more, I think, you just don't even care anymore. You don't even care enough to try. Now, that apathy, that is a bad sign, but it's not uncommon. After months, years of doing long distance with a friend, you just might not have the same depth or knowledge of each other's lives and who you really are at this point, in this chapter,
不过，有时候，一段友谊不幸地、遗憾地会让人感觉……已经无法挽回。或者更确切地说，我觉得，你甚至已经不在乎了。你甚至不在乎到懒得去尝试。这种冷漠，这是一个不好的征兆，但并不罕见。在与一个朋友维持了几个月、几年的异地恋之后，你可能只是不再拥有彼此生活的同等深度或了解，在这个阶段、在这个篇章里，
you've just changed too much while you've been apart to continue on. It's just fizzled. You don't need to feel like a failure if this is the case. I will come out and say, this has happened to me. There have been people who I have been able to maintain loving, stable friendships with for over 10 years of not living in the same place. And there are others where it is just quietly fizzled after only three months. Because, you know, we just weren't the same people.
你们在分开期间改变得太多了，以至于无法继续下去。它就这样无疾而终了。如果情况确实如此，你不需要觉得自己是个失败者。我要站出来说，这种事发生在我身上过。有些人，即使不住在同一个地方，我也能维持长达10年充满爱、稳定的友谊；而另一些人，仅仅三个月就悄悄无疾而终了。因为，你知道的，我们不再是同一个人了。
There was a mutual agreement that we didn't have. have the space and the time to invest that extra effort. Like we said at the very beginning of this episode, you know, some 50% of long-distance friendships don't work out. And I truly believe that we cannot keep every single friend that we make. Unfortunately, sometimes there does have to be that exodus or that shedding of relationships that no longer fit into the puzzle of your life to make room for new people, especially if this has been caused by a mutual lack of effort.
我们达成了一种共识，即我们没有空间和时间去投入那份额外的努力。正如我们在本集一开始所说的那样，你知道的，大约50%的异地友谊并没有长久。我坚信，我们无法留住我们结交的每一个朋友。不幸的是，有时确实必须经历那种大迁徙，或者抛弃那些不再适合你生活拼图的关系，以便为新的人腾出空间，特别是如果这是由双方共同缺乏努力引起的。
So in the aftermath of this, it can feel really difficult because you feel guilty, maybe betrayed, hurt, maybe a little bit unsatisfied. Just try not to make yourself or the other person a villain. Try and be neutral towards the situation, or at least neutral towards what caused the situation. no one betrayed anyone. No one is an evil friend because a friendship fizzled. It's kind of like the same way that we have to accept that death is part of life. Friendship breakups are also a part and a promised part of this journey and of this decade. So just letting the distance take over naturally, ending things amicably without any fuss, it also leaves the door open for them to return when timing and context, is better. No anger, no bitterness, just a sense of peace with the way that the cards were dealt. And who's to say that if the distance hadn't occurred, this wouldn't have happened anyway? You know, sometimes it's not the distance that always causes the friendship to end.
所以在这一切之后，感觉可能会非常艰难，因为你会感到内疚、或许还有背叛感、受伤感，可能还有一点点不满足。尽量不要把自己或对方塑造成坏人。尽量对这种情况保持中立，或者至少对导致这种情况的原因保持中立。没有人背叛任何人。没有人因为一段友谊消亡而成为邪恶的朋友。这有点像我们必须接受死亡是生命的一部分一样。友谊的破裂也是这段旅程和这个十年中不可或缺、注定要经历的一部分。所以，顺其自然地让距离接管一切，毫无小题大做地和平结束事情，这也为他们在时机和背景更合适时回归敞开了大门。没有愤怒，没有痛苦，只有对命运安排的一种平静。谁又能说，如果没有发生距离的问题，这一切就不会发生呢？你知道的，有时并不是距离导致了友谊的终结。
Sometimes it's just that you are changing as people. Sometimes it's just that you are in new errors or new chapters of your life. you have different priorities. You have other friends that you no longer share mutual friendships with. You see your life differently. You have a partner. They don't have a partner. You work in different fields when you used to work as colleagues in the same kind of profession.
有时只是因为你们作为人都在改变。有时只是因为你们处于生活的新阶段或新篇章。你们有不同的优先事项。你们有其他不再共享共同朋友圈的朋友。你们看待生活的方式不同了。你有了伴侣。他们没有伴侣。你们在不同的领域工作，而过去你们曾是同一行业的同事。
So don't always just assume that it's because you failed at the long distance thing. Sometimes it is the case that this may have just happened. The distance just sped things up. And we see this in romantic relationships quite a bit. So I just want you to rest assured at the, just to end of this episode, long distance friendships in your 20s are difficult. They are also common. They do require effort.
所以不要总是认为这是因为你在异地恋这件事情上失败了。有时事实确实如此，这种情况就是会发生。距离只是加速了事情的发展。我们在浪漫关系中也经常看到这一点。所以我只想让你在这一集的结尾感到放心，20多岁的异地友谊是很艰难的。它们也很常见。它们确实需要付出努力。
So you need to consider, is this an investment that I want to make? Do I see a long-term future with this friend? And do I see a future long enough that I'm going to be willing to continue to put in this effort for a long time to come? That is a question you have to ask yourself. I do think though that it is worth it. It is so 100% worth it to have people who you love and who you care about in different countries, in different cities, in different places. Because then you have this whole beautiful network of people that you get to go and visit and that you're excited to see and, you know, that you get to surprise.
所以你需要考虑：这是一笔我想进行的投资吗？我能看到我和这位朋友有长期的未来吗？我看到的未来是否足够长久，以至于我愿意在未来很长一段时间里继续付出这种努力？这是你必须问自己的一个问题。不过我确实认为这是值得的。拥有那些你爱的人、你关心的人在不同的国家、不同的城市、不同的地方，这是百分之百值得的。因为这样你就拥有了一个庞大而美好的社交网络，你可以去拜访他们，你可以兴奋地去见他们，你知道的，你还可以给他们惊喜。
There's a benefit of having a long-distance friendship. You get to surprise them sometimes. And you know what? That is one of the highlights of my life is seeing the reactions from my friends when, you know, you know, you pop up. up in their city and you get this amazing weekend together. So there are many, many upsides. Another big upside is just that you get to love them for longer and you get to see each other change through this new period of your friendship. And I think that that is something that some people don't get and it's a real testament to the strength and the care and the love that you have
拥有异地友谊有一个好处。你有时可以给他们惊喜。你知道吗？这是我生命中的亮点之一，看到朋友们的反应，当你知道的，你突然出现在他们的城市，然后你们度过了一个美妙的周末。所以有非常非常多的好处。另一个巨大的好处是，你能更久地爱他们，并且能看到彼此在这个友谊的新阶段中发生改变。我认为这是有些人无法得到的，这是你们彼此拥有的坚强、关爱和真爱的真实见证。
for each other. So I hope that this episode has helped you in this kind of weird universal the experience of managing distance and friendship and the two worlds kind of combining. There are so many ways to keep the spark alive, so I hope it has inspired you. Feel free to send this to your long distance best friend. Send it to them right now. They might need these tips. Maybe it's a really great way to get on the same page to reignite something that has kind of felt a little bit stale for a while.
所以我希望这一集能对你在处理距离与友谊以及这两个世界融合这种奇妙的普遍体验时有所帮助。有很多方法可以让火花保持不灭，所以我希望它能激励到你。请随时把这个发给你异地最好的朋友。现在就发给他们吧。他们可能需要这些建议。也许这是一个重新找回共鸣、重燃那些感觉有点冷淡了一段时间的关系的绝佳方式。
Whatever it is, I'm sure they would love to hear from you anyways. Make sure that you are following us on sports. Spotify. It just means that you know when we post new episodes and we have some exciting ones coming out. Feel free to rate us to leave a comment if you would like. And I hope you guys are getting excited. We have 12 days of guests coming up very, very soon as we enter December. I cannot wait to announce who our guests will be this year. Until next time, stay safe. Stay kind. Be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
无论如何，我确信他们会很高兴听到你的消息。请务必在Spotify上关注我们。这意味着你知道我们什么时候发布新节目，而且我们接下来会有一些令人兴奋的节目。如果你愿意，请随时给我们打分、留个评论。希望大家都很兴奋。随着12月的到来，我们很快就会迎来12天的嘉宾访谈。我等不及要宣布今年我们的嘉宾会是谁了。下次见之前，保重。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在iHeart电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你对某人伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：
Gregalespian and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As this season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑都炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着本季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了精神顽强、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难。你就会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。也就是数字的2%，在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。